the willingness to be disliked is a
superpower if you develop the
willingness to be disliked you will
inevitably have the courage to do the
hard things that most people are not
willing to do this will then imbue your
life with a sense of meaning and
importance it will also lead to success
that others will be too intimidated to
go after but I would go even further
than this I would argue that until
you're comfortable with the disapproval
of others you are not truly a free
individual yourself you must develop the
ability to be disliked in order to free
yourself from the prison of other
people's opinions learn to do what's
right even if others think it might be
wrong learn to tolerate criticism and
negative feedback because that's what
will make you better learn to be laughed
at hated on in trolled because if you
can become comfortable with the hate
you'll be Unstoppable